his name's Godspeed and he's from the
future
welcome back everyone is Charlie the
flash is back this is gonna be my season
6 episode 1 video we have so many Easter
eggs to talk about its crisis on
Infinite Earths every single episode
this season the first half will deal
with crisis stuff we're doing a weekly
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your best theory about crisis on
Infinite Earths in the video careful for
spoilers if you have not seen the
episode yet so here we go top 10 WTF and
easter eggs number 10 the mystery
opening glitch in the Time Vault
we found out at the end of the episode
the monitor was responsible for this
he's like yeah I totally did it on
purpose but if you noticed during the
episode there were several moments where
they basically tried to clear a lot of
what's going on in that previous future
nor a timeline because the timeline was
wiped
even though Nora's technology survived
because it was designed to be impervious
to timeline changes that coupled with
the very first villain which I'll talk
about in a second because it was a very
big villain twist is all about them
introducing the new version of the
timeline that will play out in Easter
eggs over the rest of the season we
might not learn everything about the new
future timeline that Nora will come from
and her potential twin brother from the
comics the tornado twins until next
season but the showrunner said there
would be a lot of Easter eggs for that
so we'll just pick him out episode by
episode as we see him number 9 though
probably one of the biggest WTF the
Godspeed army that's slowly been forming
over the last four months so they do
that big-time jump four months later
after the end of last season it was a
great opening action scene they remind
you about a bunch of details from
godspeed last season that he's a
velocity-9 speedster in the world of the
flash they name drop August heart but
the big surprises is that it's just
another mechanical automaton something
that someone in the future is sending
back into the past and it's the fourth
one in as many months so they have four
different versions of godspeed locked up
in iron Heights just think about that
it's a small Godspeed army that's slowly
forming what's gonna happen if all those
versions of Godspeed escape at the same
time that seems like it's gonna blow up
in their face maybe later this season
but the whole idea is is that there's a
villain from the potential future with
the technology to create artificial god
speeds so it has to be someone that's
either really smart or from a very
distant version of the future there are
only a couple of flash films we know
that come from that far in the future in
abracadabra is one of the few ones we
have in
seen a long time also this probably has
something to do with the villain from
the second half of the season remember
even though they introduced the blood
work villain during this episode he's
only here for the first half of the
season there'll be a different bill in
the back cap and everyone obviously is
thinking might be Red Death but he's
just one of the other picks of potential
villains from the future because the
last time we heard about Red Death on
the flash was when we were in that noir
episode in the future timeline at the
flash Museum and they were mentioning
him and passing as one of the greatest
foes of the flash so just remember big
godspeed mystery coming from the future
but it's not a gas heart it's just a
bunch of artificial versions of godspeed
at this point number 8 catching up with
team flash this is where they set up the
su didney arc for ralph didney he's been
travelling all over the world because of
the file he was looking at at the end of
last season it's sooo didney from the
comics they're gonna introduce her later
this season they've already confirmed it
they didn't say which episode is gonna
happen so it could be the first half of
the season or the second half of the
season but obviously you know they get
married her name is sue Dearborn because
that's her maiden name
iris is still running the Central City
citizen things are going well with that
they catch up with team flash Cisco is
building a version of cerebro using the
Speed Force that will allow Barry to
basically see potential time lines using
the Speed Force the same way that dr.
strange used the time stone during
Avengers infinity war there were
actually a lot of Marvel references and
easter eggs during this episode but
they're calling it the mental
augmentation chamber and Barry sounds
like he wants to use it like Minority
Report
to catch crimes before they happen
because he's using potential alternate
futures to find criminals before they
actually commit the act spoiler warning
for Minority Report that never goes well
so no matter what's gonna happen with
this device things were gonna go
completely off the rails
number six meet the new blood work
villain Ramsey Rosa that's his name in
the comics they change a couple things
about his backstory they say he's one of
Caitlin's friends from medical school
and his mother who died who the funeral
was for at the beginning of the episode
is the person who got Caitlin the job at
STAR Labs in the first place
this is them giving him a lot of history
and ties to her character but you learn
that he just wants dark matter because
he's created a cure for cancer that
requires it and it might maybe turn
people into metahumans which it then
totally does at the end of the episode
if you're not familiar with the blood
work villain he actually appeared during
the negative
flash art we actually got a look onset
of a future episode I think it's episode
7 or episode 8 where we see what looks
like Barry turning into a negative flash
so we might actually get some of that
this season number 5 there are whole
bunch of Marvel Easter eggs when they're
at the junkyard
well first iris calls Cisco Ghostbusters
because of the device he's using to scan
for dark matter cisco talks about gamma
rays magnetar fields gamma rays
obviously talking about the Hulk there
was also a killer frost Caitlin Hulk
style storyline in a bit of a riff on
their storyline during Avengers infinity
war with the whole kind of fighting
banner within his mind for control of
the body
dude you're Barry from the Wizards we
get the quick reminder that Joe West is
the new police chief captain seeing I
guess has gone on to greener pastures
but maybe he'll still appear on the show
every once in a while but number four we
meet Chester P trunk from the comics he
is a flash comic book villain his
ability was opening wormholes to other
realities but when they show him on
screen there are a whole bunch of meta
Easter eggs for Star Wars and even more
Marvel Easter eggs if you look at some
of the chat names I'm probably missing a
couple of them here but there's wookie
lover 77 for Star Wars released in 1977
Pizza Parker is a reference to Tobey
Maguire's version of spider-man from
spider-man to pizza time but they find
the Chester P trunk has been connected
to the black holes somehow he's been
given this ability that allows him to
create black holes we kind of learned
it's a little more complicated than that
during the final big action scene
because berry literally flies through a
black hole and it takes him to another
part of space but that's basically what
his comic book powers are and even
though at the end of the episode they're
able to reconnect his consciousness to
his body his eyes are glowing all yellow
that just means that he'll probably be
able to continue opening portals across
the multiverse later in the season when
Sisko is talking about solutions and
creates that stellar grenade there's a
really deep cut mission impossible
Emilio Estevez reference when he says
hasta lasagna don't get any Anya
elongated man gives us a nice Superman
reference there's gonna be so many
versions of Superman coming during
crisis on Infinite Earths no tryst of
Solitude the whole killer frost thing is
basically her just being pissed off the
Caitlyn only uses her for fighting then
they work it out and she agrees to let
killer frost
the dominant personality this season so
it just means way more killer frost in
episodes than Caitlyn as you've seen
before normally it's just a little bit
of killer frost in mostly Caitlyn now
it's gonna be the other way around for
season six
just like the Flash's new costume is way
better than last year's costume her
costume is also way better than the
previous versions of her costumes but
number three the big Flash Gordon scene
I was so surprised in laughing so hard I
was so happy with the way they used this
Cisco says I've been saving this one for
a long time they play the theme song
from Flash Gordon as Barry flies into
the wormhole or the black hole just like
Flash Gordon did in his movie the brand
new ability that he's using we've never
actually seen him do before is creating
a bubble of speed force protection
around himself
Cisco refers to it as a speed force aura
to protect himself from the gravimetric
forces but he carries the consciousness
of Chester P R UNK puts it back in his
body inside their special cerebro device
then basically say that he's gonna have
to bake in there for three to four weeks
with his code for three to four episodes
such as them saying that they probably
won't be able to use that special device
for anything good for a couple more
weeks but number two blood work gets his
comic book powers so he naturally uses
the dark matter from the gun that he
acquired in the black market to test his
cure for cancer on himself it totally
works but then as caitlin foretold it
could turn people into metahumans it's
straight-up turns him into comic-book
blood work the way they visualized his
powers is similar to the way his powers
work in the comics but they tune down
the bright red and now it's a little
more real-world if you didn't read that
flash rebirth auric he just has the
ability to control blood he can create
constructs he can control the blood in
other people including the flash so he
can actually partially control the flash
by controlling his blood that might have
something to do with the negative flash
stuff that we've seen from them on set
but while Barry was on the other side of
space through that black hole he grabbed
Nora's jacket which had been sucked in
and they put it in the place where they
used to keep reverse flashes costume
inside the Time Vault reverse flash is a
big part of crisis on Infinite Earths
just like he said last season he will be
back I'll see you at the next crisis
our next crisis
[Music]
then big number one WTF the end credits
scene crisis on Infinite Earths the
monitor rolls in and explains why he
destroyed Nora's device because I don't
want you to have hope because in order
for billions to survive the flash must
die so it's basically him giving him a
comic book spoiler for crisis on
Infinite Earths in no surprise episode 2
next week is called a flash of the
lightning that's the name of the issue
where flash died during crisis on
Infinite Earths so that's why next week
Barry is gonna travel to the future to
try and get a glimpse and see what
really happens and then he goes to Jay
Garrick for help so next week big Jay
Garrick episode but he did put an actual
date on the Flash's death now I think we
all believe that Oliver Queen is gonna
sacrifice himself that's the whole point
of this is that he's going to do
something different so that Barry does
not disappear during crisis but the
actual day is December 10th 2019 that's
just gonna be the day of the flash
episode of the crossover see how they
did that this is the full schedule for
all the episodes of the crossover first
three airing in December then they go on
break then come back in January you get
the second part of the crossover then
whatever explosive conclusion so they
really are gonna kill off Oliver Queen
that might not wind up happening till
the January episodes but everybody post
your favorite moments from the episode
in the comments if you have any big
questions or there any Easter eggs you
spotted that I didn't mention in the
video I feel like it was a great first
episode way better than season 5 way
better than season 4 there is a brand
new showrunner who's actually working on
the show so he did a great job of
setting a whole bunch of stuff up for
future episodes and for the back half of
the season like I said I think the God
speed stuff might be connected to the
back half of the season what'll happen
is is I'll do a trailer video for
Episode two and post that tomorrow I
named a giveaway winner when I do that
while you wait for everything click here
for all my flash crisis on Infinite
Earths
trailer videos and learn about what's
going on with all the Superman and click
here for all my Joker movie videos
Easter eggs the ending scene in my
review video thank you so much for
watching everybody
you